is an 8 news now breaking news alert
thanks for joining us here at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis three
people are dead one hurt in separate
incidents here in the valley police say
neither are random acts of violence so
here's a look at both of the shootings
the first happening near mlk and kerry
that happened earlier tonight but we
start near lake mead in hollywood
madison kimbrough is there with an
update
yes a married couple who was in their
50s was found dead in their bathtub here
at their condo here at moonlight terrace
complex now apparently the man emailed
an out of state family member letting
them know that this was going to take
place and to come to the condo
afterwards that family member
immediately contacted metro this
afternoon and that's when authorities
arrived on scene
reading the email that was sent to the
family member we believe this is going
to be a murder-suicide investigation
based upon details that were put into
that e-mail and also notes in
items left behind inside the house for
other family members
the man died from a self-inflicted
gunshot wound but metro says it's still
unclear how the woman died metro says a
will was left in writing stating what
items should go to whom this is the
second murder-suicide investigation this
week after a man and boy were killed on
sunday that was also in north las vegas
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now
mattis